>>> THERE WE GO, SWEETIE.
>> I'M A MOM, THAT DOESN'T MEAN
I DON'T LIKE TO HAVE FUN.
>> I DRIVE A MINIVAN, BUT I CAN
LET LOOSE A LITTLE TOO.
>> I WANT TO USE HEROIN, I ALSO
WANT TO GET STUFF DONE.
THAT'S WHY I REACH FOR HEROIN
AM.
THE ONLY NONDROWSY HEROIN ON THE
MARKET.
SO I CAN GET JACKED ON SCAGG AND
THEN GET TO WORK.
>> THERE WAS ALMOST A STIGMA
ABOUT INJECTING BLACK TAR
HEROIN.
BUT I'M ALMOST MORE ALERT THAN
IF I WEREN'T ON HEROIN.
>> HEROIN USE IN AMERICA IS
STEADILY ON THE RISE.
PRODUCTIVITY AMONG HEROIN USERS
HAS REMAINED STAGNANT.
>> THAT'S WHY HEROIN AM COMBINES
HEROIN WITH CAFFEINE AND A SMALL
PILE OF COCAINE.
>> NOW AVAILABLE IN GUMMY BEARS
WHICH YOU CAN MELT DOWN AND
INJECT.
>> SIDE EFFECTS INCLUDE, IT'S
HEROIN SO ALL THAT STUFF.
>> NOW I ASK CHASE THE DRAGON
WHILE I ALSO CHASE THIS LITTLE
GUY.
>> I'M GONNA GET YA.
>> THIS MIGHT BE THE FIRST
AFTERNOON MOM DOESN'T NEED A
NAP.
[ GIGGLING ]
[ SCREAMING ]
>> HEROIN AM, FROM THE MAKERS OF
COCAINE PM.
>> I WENT FROM NODDING OFF TO
NODDING YES TO MORE HEROIN.
NOW, WHO'S READY FOR SCHOOL?
[ CHEERING ]
[ APPLAUSE ]